ministers meeting at the General Affairs
Council prepared work ahead of the march
EU summit which main focus will be to
promote the creation of an energy union
the aim is to make the EU market more
competitive more sustainable and to
ensure security of supply I believe that
European Council later this week will be
able to agree on some pillars creating
energy union that's security solidarity
also development of internal energy
market efficiency the carburizing
decarbonizing of energy sources and
development of research the council has
also examined external relations issues
they include preparations for the next
Eastern Partnership summit in Riga as
well as relations with Russia and the
situation in Ukraine and Libya the
European economy was also on the agenda
ministers have discussed the European
fund for strategic investment and ways
that it can contribute to growth and
jobs in the EU moreover the council made
preparations for the first phase of the
European semester 4 2015 where Member
States agree on economic and fiscal
policy priorities for a given year